[THEME MUSIC]
TIMOTHY JORDON: This is I/O
live, and I'm Timothy Jordan.
I'm standing here
with Riccardo, who's
working on a really cool machine
learning project that he's
going to tell us about.
Hi, Riccardo.
RICCARDO SABATINI: Hey, hello.
Hi, everyone.
TIMOTHY JORDON: Could you give
us an overview of the work
that you're doing?
RICCARDO SABATINI: Yes.
So we are working on, and we
managed to close a technology
to give us, visibility on how
a small molecule is interacting
not with just a piece of your
genome-- the usual design--
but on the entire protean.
And with the best
approximation we can get.
A nice assay biological test.
And this is giving us visibility
that we never had before.
So we are working to
release a database where
these small molecule
interactions are going
to map of all our genomes.
And this I think will open up
a complete new design principle
on small molecules, new
exciting algorithms, and better
precision into robotics.
TIMOTHY JORDON: Awesome.
Now this is a
really big problem,
with a really big solution.
What about an everyday
problem that you would love
to solve with machine learning?
RICCARDO SABATINI: I think will
be probably choosing my food.
So today we get to a grocery
store or to a restaurants,
we pick our food mostly by use.
So we are used to buy a
specific kind of things.
And we repeat over
and over again.
But if I had in my
calendar, or my agenda,
when I go to the gym,
if I have meetings,
I have my Fitbit or my
sleeping wearable device
that tells me if I slept a
lot, or if I'm close to 40.
I'd love someone to solve that.
You should eat this,
this, and that,
and remember that you
have an early meeting.
Don't eat too much
or too late tonight.
Or drink some milk, or get
some vitamin D in winter.
Boom.
I would change my life.
TIMOTHY JORDON: I
would probably still
sneak in some gummy
bears, though.
RICCARDO SABATINI: You can
totally tweak the algorithm
and add a naughty [INAUDIBLE]
so you can pick up some sugar,
if you like it.
TIMOTHY JORDON:
Awesome, Riccardo.
Thanks so much for joining
us and sharing your story.
RICCARDO SABATINI: Thanks
for having me here.
Thank you.
TIMOTHY JORDON: And thank
you, for watching I/O live.
Now that we've heard
a little bit more
about what ML is
being applied to,
let's go check out some of
the technology behind all
this machine learning research.
Shall we?
Head on over to the ML sandbox?
Let's do that.
[THEME MUSIC]